a lot of people are absolutely obsessed
with their max strength that's the
maximum amount of strength a person can
produce regardless of how big or small
they
are strength to weight ratio of course
is how strong you are in relation to how
big you are how heavy you are and to me
this is better for a whole number of
reasons for one it obviously means you
can jump higher run faster climb more
easily because you have greater control
over your body
weight beyond that a good strength
weight ratio normally means you're going
to have a pretty good physique because
you're going to want to build strength
build muscle whilst also reducing your
weight I.E reducing excess body
[Music]
fat so you're going to be quite
lean of course things like calisthenic
skills it's also quite important